thank you good evening and welcome to
this meeting of the planning committee
and welcome to those watching online if
the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices via the stairs
through the back of the the room here
please do not use the lifts please
assemble in hly square on the green
where officers will assist you and
advise you when it is deemed safe to
return to the chamber does anyone intend
to film the
meeting I would advise that speakers
using the microphones are picked up by
the cameras recording the meeting me
members of the public in the public
Gallery behind the speakers may be
picked up by those cameras and have
their image captured any member of the
public who objects to the possibility of
being filmed may wish to take this
opportunity to move or leave the
meeting would everyone present please
ensure their mobile phones are turned to
silent and that they are not used to
make or receive phone calls in the
chamber whilst this meeting is in
progress I don't have any members who
have asked to speak under Council
procedure rule 20.1
and there are no members in the chamber
who are not member of the committee so
there won't be any to add to that the
following applications have been
reserved for public speaking item 5B
which is 52a Stone Road
broadstairs agenda item one I have
apologies from councelor Dennis
councelor makinson and councelor Moore
there are no
substitutions it agenda item
two sorry yeah I have an apology from
councelor Wing she's had a a roof
emergency with the rain all coming
through okay thank you apologies I
didn't ask for that I was getting
excited and getting ahead of myself
councelor Wing um are there any
Declarations of Interest councelor Orban
and myself councilor Orban yeah chair um
I have a declaration of interest in item
5e uh it's an application by Ramsgate
Town Council and as a chair of Ramsgate
Town Council I've had some involvement
in the uh not in the process of the of
the application but uh in discussions uh
relating to it so I'm declaring an
interest here thank
you thank you I also have to declare an
interest on the same agenda item as I am
chair of the Town promotion committee at
Ramsgate Town Council what that does
mean is that uh Vice chair councel W
will take over chairing this meeting at
the end of the items reserved for public
speaking um next item item three do
members agree that minutes of the
planning committee meeting held on the
20th of September 23 be approved as a
correct record and can I have a proposal
please I I call councelor byford's hand
first and councelor album for secondar
if that's all right with you councelor
Alban um do members agree agree thank
you um the planning applications manager
will now outline a point of information
about item 5A Northwood Court
broadstairs thank you chair um just a
brief point of information on a couple
of points with regards the report for
Northwood Court um the relevant planning
History Section in that report omits one
application from 2019 which was an
application uh for a certificate of
lawful development uh which was stated
that the existing use of the building
was as a a collection of C4 houses in
multiple occupation and that was refused
um in addition in that report the
planning policy comment um referred to a
document which is the economic
development in thanet employment land
update and economic needs assessment
July 2018 uh but that was actually
emitted from the summary of the comment
so that is a relevant document that was
mentioned by the planning policy team
thank you
agenda item four hang on where am I yeah
you're yeah sorry I'm I'm I'm catching
up agenda item four um the planning
applications manager will now outline
the report it was just an unusual one
thank
you thank you chair um so this is an
application being reported back to um
members was considered it June's
committee so this is an applic to vary
condition two on an application for uh
to vary conditions on four houses
specifically that related to the removal
of four trees from an application site
um and also a change in the ground
levels uh of the site now the proposal
was deferred back to officers to seek
amendments to the layout and to look at
measures to actually retain the four
trees in question uh no was raised at
the time to the change in the ground
levels um so the applicant has provided
a statement from their AR culturalist
about why they consider the tree should
be removed and they haven't changed
their proposal and therefore it falls
for members to consider and to determine
the application so I'll just go through
the photos so we've got the site um is
the undeveloped land uh where the point
in red is on Soul Street you've got
Crawford Road at the rear and the
primary school to the rear as
well this is a 3D image from Google it's
it's not particularly clear but it's to
try and give a sense of the fact that
the trees are primarily located at the
front of the site adjacent to the
boundary with soul
Street um this is a view from Soul
Street uh looking at the boundary wall
which is to be retained as part of the
development and the trees um directly
adjacent to that boundary wall so these
trees are protected up by virtue of a
TPO the TPO covers the whole site um and
is an AA order from 1974 so it only
protects the trees that were present in
1974 which includes the trees at the
front that you can see in this image and
also in this
image um this is the view from Crawford
Road and you can see one particular tree
that's uh in the foreground next to the
the the neighboring property but then
the trees that you were just looking at
are the ones that sort of form the bank
of that view uh at the rear of the site
in from this view but obviously the
front of the site from Soul Street and
then this is a view further back again
you can see the tree line at the top
there and some trees on the
boundary so this was the plan of the
approved scheme so four detached
dwellings approved using the existing
vehicle access um and the proposal came
forward and was approved by members uh
well a number of years ago now um with
the retention of the vast majority of
trees on the
site so the change in land levels that
um is proposed um relates specifically
to unit four which is the one on the
left hand side it's a relatively minor
change and it's not even necessarily
perceivable from from flicking between
but it's ever so slightly increased in
height uh but members didn't raise any
concern with it previously and obviously
it's it's still our opinion that that
there's no issue in terms of the
character of the area with the change
that's
occurred so the main issue relates to
the trees in question so this is a plan
submitted showing the trees on the site
at the moment now um to give you some
context of what you're looking at the
dotted lines that run around the trees
see there are multiple Circles of are
showing the root protection areas of the
trees whereas the canopy of the trees
themselves are the solid lines um now
originally the application proposed to
remove five trees from the site which
included an ash tree which is 16 uh
which has a category B tree which is the
one in blue down on the bottom right
however that is that's been emitted from
the application it's not proposed to
remove that tree uh but the four other
trees that to be submit so to be removed
are shown in the areas in red on this
plan here so they're all sycamore trees
it's our view that because of their age
and their maturity uh that they are they
were not present in 1974 so they are not
covered by the TPO in our view they are
however shown on the plan originally
approved for uh retention just as part
of the layout um and so obviously this
is why we've got the application in
before us to try and remove those um the
application stated that originally that
it's the the location of the tree
um effectively were compromised by the
low of the site to be able to get the
vehicle access not the vehicle access
sorry the the um access route through um
and there is in Annex one a a summary
letter provided by the applicant arbic
culturist about why it's considered that
that those trees could be removed
primarily that relates to two issues one
practicalities about a no dig solution
which was something that um members will
recall councelor pressland talked about
um potentially looking at as to whether
or not you could put a geoc cell system
down and try and effectively try build
around the um the trees that were there
um but the other issue that's been
raised as well as a change in level
across the site which the arbic
culturalist um has has stated would be
would make it extremely problematic to
try to retain these trees is also that
they're not considered by the applicant
to offer significant ameny value and
therefore are not almost worthy of
retention on the side and would
compromise any layout that would be
provided now um the section of the
report where we've talked about the
particular issue with potentially
refusing the application is paragraph
3.4 uh which really looks at the
question of if you were to remove those
trees what harm does it cause to the
character of the area um particularly
noting that all of the other trees at
the front are are protected and they're
proposed to be retained now one of the
issues that has come up here is that you
are losing trees that whilst not um not
RV present in 1974 are still um have
still been there for a number of years
and they do offer um you know ecological
value and potential habitat for bird
species um they would be that would be
lost and the applicant is proposing to
effectively provide five replacement
trees at the rear to replace some of the
the sort of more um small level scrub um
grow that you've got along the back
elevation with sorry the back of the
site with um a combination of Silver
Birch and field Maples that are native
species rather than the syore trees that
are being removed which are non-native
however it's appreciated that new trees
do not have the same ecological value
they do not offer the same habitat that
you get to species initially uh and
therefore there is a there's a trade off
there between getting native species but
not having the same ecological value um
but even so um the assessment has to be
on the basis that if that these trees
are vital for protection and that we
would effectively refuse the application
which is still an application for four
houses even though it's a variation of
condition it's still an application for
four houses um on the basis of that that
these trees do contribute significantly
to the character of the area now the
only public realm view of these trees is
from uh Crawford Road um but as as shown
by the images is they are barely
perceivable in comparison to the larger
trees at the front of the side which are
the older trees and the ones that
obviously we we want to see protected um
in terms of so that's just a more
detailed view um of where the access is
coming in and the trees that had be
protected around the access um if I
click through what we do have and please
ignore the red circle around uh tree 16
in the bottom right um that was
obviously this this was produced before
uh that part of this application was
emitted what we have had as part of the
discharge of other conditions is the
aricultural method statement which has
detailed um you know no dig areas for
the trees um which are to be retained at
the front of the site um it includes
information about the surfacing that's
to be put down for vehicles to end the
site um on a base level that's um that
raises up above the The Roots themselves
um there are design storage areas on the
hard surfacing once laid so that you're
not putting anything underneath the
canopy of the trees that be retained um
and this has been approved as part of
the discharge of condition following it
being looked at by our our tree
consultant um to to consider whether or
not it's adequate in terms of the
measures to protect you also sorry
include the protective fencing that goes
around the base of the trees as well
um so the only other point I want to
draw members attention to is is uh I
understand from the debate last time
that there is a a a understandable sense
of frustration from members that the
applicant has indicated that they're
going to keep the trees uh and then
they're now proposing that they're not
going to be able to keep the trees um
but um we're still required to consider
it on its own merits and the officer
view is that the four trees and the
limited visual impact that they provide
simply wouldn't justify a reason for
refusal on its own
um given that these trees wouldn't in
our view be worthy of a TPO in and of
themselves um and therefore the
application to remove those four trees
is is recommended for approval thank you
chair thank you I move that the
officer's recommendation is adopted
would the vice chair please second
seconded and I've got councelor Garner
and yeah I'll start with start with
councelor
Garner thank you thank you I appreciate
that we um here we are again so to help
me and hopefully others with this I
Revisited um pre the pre this
application that this is seeking to
amend and I was on the planning
committee as were two or three others of
us here when um we when I'd called it in
and when we discussed it and looking at
the officer's report that was produced
for that that debate um
in
2021 I believe it was the planet
application was raised in
2020 it was obvious that the applicant
and the officer had been in quite
extensive discussions about the
retention of or otherwise of these trees
whether they're tped or not because at
the initial stage there was quite there
were concerns raised that they were
being lost those trees but by the tree
officer and the planning officer so the
applicant to bate those concerns and to
make this application more acceptable
told us through their application that
they would implement this um planning
application by retaining those trees now
whether these trees are worthy of TPO or
not they were felt worthy of retention
at that time and I I had concerns about
the planning application B STS and town
and St Peters Town Council had concerns
about the planning application which is
why I called it in for discussion and we
did have quite a long debate about it
and after a debate we were
convinced uh to vote to approve that
planning application I voted to approve
the plan application and part of the
reason I voted to approve the plan
application along with the others was
because we had been convinced by the
applicant that those trees were being
retained and I find it
ging I know Council Everett had a had a
phrase about planning applications that
came back after being approved and then
changed I can't remember exactly what it
was but it was taking something taking
the something and I I I find it
extremely ging that they despite us then
discussing it again in June and
outlining uh how we felt about it that
they haven't been able to come back and
retain those trees um so I'm I'm loathed
to support this amendment but I I can't
imagine anyone being able to convince me
to do that because I'm I'm getting a bit
fed up with um our requests and our
approvals of planning applications being
being um overlooked or being being
ignored and so I I don't think I'm going
to support this this this
recommendation although obviously I'm
always interested to hear what other
members of the committee have to say
thank you thank you councilor matterface
um this is me just being pedantic in the
executive summary my first point uh the
planning application was reported on the
14th of June 2022
looks like that really confused me when
I was reading through hang on a minute
uh that was just a minor point but I do
have a question um about these native
trees that will be planted to replace
the ones that may or may not come down
um how can we be sure that the trees
that are going to be put on the Crawford
Road side will be themselves protected
because correct me if I'm wrong if if
they plant saplings you can't TPO a
sapling it's is that
correct so if we if we insist on mature
trees if we agree to the these being cut
down we would need to ensure that they
had some form of protection because
what's going to happen two years down
the line somebody in that unit one says
oh those trees are shadowing my garden
I'd like them taken down and we would
have nothing to stop them doing that
would
we um so the trees that would be plant
the rear of the garden would not be
protected as you say by TPO um we have
through the application the original
application and clearing the conditions
agreed U effectively the the terms that
they will be planted they will be
maintained and if they do fail within
the normal period of 5 years then they
would be replanted um so that is
something that we would still have as a
planning condition which would be
breached if if technically there was an
issue the the point I suppose about
those trees as they are are on the the
ones that are being removed is there is
technically there is no protection other
than the planning condition afforded to
them at the moment so if this
application doesn't actually get
implemented hasn't been implemented yet
um and they actually only have a few
months to do that because of when the
approval was um the trees could be taken
out and there would be no breach
condition because they wouldn't have
actually implemented the consent so the
protection that the trees are afforded
is only through the planning condition
of the layout which is not a
it's not really a strong protection in
of itself but we are trying to make sure
that the trees that are planted are of a
decent caliber and are of of an age so
that's why obviously we've got the
Landscaping conditions on as normal and
we are trying to make sure that for new
development sites uh basically for
houses that we are getting the
Landscaping checked during the course of
construction in this specific instance
we will need to be checking because of
of the very detailed arbac cultural
method statement that we've had for the
trees at the front um and it is a big
concern that we have of small
developments like this we've had quite a
few in the district at the moment where
you know the statement hasn't been
followed through with in terms of
protection of those trees I appreciate
that doesn't give the comfort about the
trees that are being planted but the aim
here is to try and provide something
that won't actually because of where
they are and these are whilst they're
native species they're not actually
massive trees this is not Sycamore size
and trees in terms of the field Maple
and the Silver Birch they are or
ornamental primarily and therefore the
size of them is unlikely to inhibit any
owners so I think the risk is minimal in
comparison to the other way but that's I
appreciate my my just my perspective on
that um that's fine but I mean I could
take you tomorrow to an area where the
can this is going back some years where
the condition was that X number of trees
I can't remember that had to be planted
not one was ever planted because
enforcement is the big issue because if
if we say that's fine you can plant
those trees but nobody two years down
the line 3 years down the line is
checking except Council Garner walking
by cuz it lives nearby um those trees
could be taken down overnight and we
wouldn't have any control over it would
we I I know this is I I've mentioned it
a few times and I think it came up in
the over in scrutiny meeting recently
there is a um a particular Point here
about enforcement when it comes to
Landscaping we have served um a number
of breach condition notices about
Landscaping specifically in the last few
years and we're actually Prosecuting a
couple of developers at the moment to do
with that this is something that we know
is a big concern of the planning
committee and therefore we are looking
to make sure that we are on top of you
know these schemes and we've got now
we've got you know a tree assistant
who's visiting the sites and and we've
got um a number of people that are
working on this on a sort of monthly
basis to go through all the new
development sites so I I think in terms
of how that affects the
determination I I want to be able to
give members the comfort that the
conditions that are on the application
are going to be adhered to and if
they're not adhered to we'll do
something about it otherwise we wouldn't
put them on um and I appreciate that
sort of history of what may have
happened or not happened in this
instance and there are other examples I
know I've spoke to council about a
number of them where these things
haven't been followed up um but I
suppose I'm just trying to make sure
that everyone knows that we are
following this stuff up and obviously if
any members are aware of things like
this where it is a breach we will follow
that up and we will go after people
specifically to do with
trees thank you councilor
Kean thank you um a lot of of what I was
going to say has been covered by
councilor matterface um but you know
because I'm particularly interested in
we lose these trees and the trees at the
back which I presume from what I can see
on the diagram are all in people's back
Gardens are at risk um but you know as I
say Obviously we've had the information
about that and the limit to what we can
do about that um what size do we specify
the size the trees have to be you say
they're not going to be saplings but how
big are they going to we do I I can't I
can't get to the information without
coming out of the presentation so I
might be able to do that for you if you
want the details of the condition I'm
going ask Annabelle potentially if you
go to uniform and get that reference
up um if we have if we have time we can
come back on the details that was
submitted as part of the the planning
condition which has come through I don't
have that to hand um but um yeah so
we'll try we'll try and get that
information you can see um the I think
the the definition that the um of the
difference in the tree so you've got the
in this image here in terms of the
actual uh the types of tree you've got
the the Silver Birch Tree um and then
the the field Maple uh as the two
varieties the AC is the the field Maple
and the the BC is the the Birch sorry
the BP is the Birch um but I'm afraid I
don't have the exact details of that and
we'll see we'll see if we can get it to
you at the moment trying to get
access
thank you I mean from reading the um
aric culturalist report um I don't see
from a planning perspective what we can
do about it but I do share Council
Garner's
frustration that we approve one thing
and then something else comes back thank
you councilor
Orbin thank you chair I do I think
there's something we can do about it um
and let not approve it however a couple
of questions first could I ask um one
this location is not in the conservation
area no thank you um two um do we know
whether the any of these sycamores that
we're talking about has ever been
pollarded at
all
firstly no specifically the the trees in
red that to be removed so they're
category C trees so they're not
considered to have a long lifespan and
of low amenity value but there's no
evidence that they've been poed the one
that's the sorry the three of them are
category C the one at the bottom is a
category u tree which is unlikely to
well there is there would be no
justification in keeping that
fundamentally it's going to fail soon
enough and therefore it needs to come
out it's on the property boundary as
well so that's a safety issue so that
definitely needs to be
CH can I come back yeah I I I just think
um obviously as then as the the the
trees that are not part of the
preservation order and it's not in a
Conservation Area then the owner of the
land the developer of the land can
remove those trees without any consent
from
TDC
however however um looking at the the
photos long soci I think it's all part
it's it's all part of it uh and I think
there's work that could be carried out
to those trees by the developer that
that could make them stay now I I fully
support what councilor Garner said about
the
um let's let's just say uh the developer
obviously wanted to get his his
application maybe said what he was going
to say to enable him to get his consent
um personally I I can't support this
thank
you Council
bayford thank you chair um I also share
Council Garner's annoyance that the um
applicant has sort of got around the
system however there doesn't seem to be
any illegality to this and we're left
with what's before
us the fact is there are four smart new
homes for families which we need and in
view of the what's been discussed the
fact that these trees could be removed
anyway
um makes me feel that I really should
support this application thank
you Council Orin yeah sorry chair I
should I I should have mentioned that
the um that the trees in in the proposed
back Gardens of the development should
just be seen as a bonus not as an not as
a an alternative because it's taken away
from the actual Street Scene the the
whole cover of that the whole tree cover
of it along Soul street so great let's
have those trees in the back Gardens and
let's let let's have them as a bonus and
not as an
alternative I have a question myself
which may be playing slightly Devil's
Advocate I do agree with Council Garner
and Council Alburn about feeling as
though we've um had our arms Twisted a
bit but I wonder what um a forestry type
um comment would be with regards to the
viability of um at least the three trees
at category C given that we've heard
that they're self-seeded and
overshadowed by the bigger trees and are
they taking away nutrients from the
bigger trees are they actually
potentially detrimental and what's their
survivability in that
situation thanks chair yeah just on on
that point particularly this is
something that has been raised by The
arbic culturalist View that's that's
come back into the council and again is
something that we would normally look at
doing as as a matter of of Forestry when
there is a there is an application to
remove trees within even groups of
protected trees if they are taking away
from U more mature and more um uh better
amenity value trees um just to come back
on the point with regards to um the
immunity value of the trees I understand
what's being stated about the fact that
it's considered to be sort of a group of
trees however we are having to look at
the individual trees themselves that's
the the purpose in terms of the
application what they've proposed to do
and these trees because of their size
because of their
spread you simply wouldn't be able to
discern from outside of the site other
than the category u tree that because of
its condition uh can't be retained um
they they simply you know n you just do
not have an impact a beneficial impact
on the street scene you wouldn't be able
to almost see that they're there from
the other trees and the bank of trees so
in terms of sustaining a reason for
refusal um it's it's simply our view
that that it's again was regrettable
because frankly you know I appreciate
members are incredibly frustrated about
this it's just not tenable point of
refusal in our
view I have count councilor Orin first
thank you chair um
self-seeded well whether a tree is
self-seeded or not I mean if it's there
it's there um and um you know you could
have planted you could have planted
sycamores but they grow naturally wild
anyway but facts of the matter is that
we've also got this is to do with the
condition on the planet not the
development per se a condition in
relation to these trees so effectively
what what we've done we self-seeded this
condition on it right so for me uh for
me that condition stays the same as
those trees stay Thank
You councilor
brigh yeah I I think I I feel really
conflicted about this um I travel past
this road every single day um um um and
those trees are very important in that
road but um obviously the ones at the
front the tped ones they're totally
precious um I don't know I'm being told
that the four trees proposed for removal
don't contribute to that canopy cover I
don't know I'm trusting Mr Livingston
here I I don't know it's only probably
only when they're removed will realize
actually the impact that you know there
there's no way of knowing
um apart from Maybe a site visit to get
inside and to actually see but I know
from going past it's a very dense you
can see it's it's a dense canopy and
it's and it's beautiful and it's full of
birds so um I'm very nervous about it um
my only if if we were to uh prove this
application I'd want an absolute
guarantee that those TPO trees at the
front everything is done to protect
those and that maybe I don't know how
regular the forcement people can go to
actually check that they are being
looked after especially as this uh the
developer said originally that he would
keep these trees it's almost like well
how do I trust him that he's going to
look after these tped ones as well so I
feel really really nervous and I I'm
really not sure about how I'm going to
what I'm going to do but willing to
carry on listening okay I've got
councelor bayford
next I'm sorry I thought I saw I thought
I saw you put your hand up just
now in that case before you I've got
councelor matterface thank you and
that's the picture from Crawford Road so
could we please have the picture
actually from Soul
Street possible at all from
that to part from the car part to rather
obstructive way can we see any of the
trees that are being proposed to take to
be taken down from that photo
no councelor ratan and then councelor
Garner after uh whilst I agree with all
the members comments um I sort of think
what Ian was saying what stopping the
developer after we refuse the
application he then takes the trees down
puts an application in with no trees in
in in the back in and then we've lost
then the the opportunity to lease to
have some trees put put back in
there and Council gner thank you yeah I
was just going to really comment on the
on the conversation about these poor old
trees because when we as I mentioned
when we talked about this at the
committee initially off and we we heard
about the negotiations that have been
going on about whether they should be
kept or whether they shouldn't be kept
they were all very valuable then you
know we' we we we'd been persuaded to
support this application because they
were keeping these trees that you may
not be able to see when you walk down
there but the the wild life the birds
that live in it the insects that live in
them they're not really that bothered
about whether I can see them when I'm
walking down that street they they're
still all living in there and as Council
Auburn says self-seeded I mean up until
not that long ago most trees in the
country were self-seeded that's how they
live that's how life sustains itself and
lives because it self seeds however that
self-seeding goes on so I should leave
it there thank you I have councelor
bayford thank you I agree whether they
are tpod or whatever the trees are
important of course they're important
but so are homes for people to live in
and I think in view of the fact that
they're aging trees other trees are
going to be planted I think we have to
be prepared to move on thank
you right well I don't appear to have
any other request to speak so we will
now put the motion for the officer's
recommendation for approval to the vote
those in
favor and those
against and
extensions
that is carried yeah that's
carried okay thank you we've moved on to
agenda item five um any site visits that
take place for committee members will be
on the morning of Friday the 3rd of
November at
9:30 uh we have one item for public
speaking item A2 52a Stone Road speaking
in favor of this application is Mrs
Anita godal um you have three
minutes
microphone Madame chair officers and
members of the committee thank you for
letting me speak in support of our
retrospective application for our back
Garden I hope you were able to look at
the photographs I left to support this
when we had building Works carried out
recently we were left with a lot of
rubble in our back Garden as our rear
Garden sloped considerably we thought
this would be a good opportunity to
level our garden neither our Builder nor
the building controls steam nor the
Landscaping Company indicated that
planning permission would be needed for
this project so the thought that it
would did not cross our minds the
leveling and Landscaping was completed
early February we were surprised to
receive a letter mid-march informing us
that our neighbor to the North 54 Stone
Road had objected and planning
permission was needed we put in a
retrospect planning application in May
54 Stone Road immediately raised
objections exciting loss of privacy loss
of light feeling of enclosure loss of
property value we do not agree any of
these are affected and this is supported
by the case officer's report following a
site visit regarding his privacy we can
easily look into his rear Garden from
our balcony and if you see the pictures
I supplied three and four show you the
view of his back Garden whereas when we
stand in our raised garden we have
nowhere near so much of a view view may
I also mention that he provided photos
in his objections that are totally
misleading one has been taken from a
height another has been taken with the
fence down you now have current
photographs of what we can actually see
when we stand in our garden looking at
his
property we have sought to alleviate any
privacy issues by planting evergreen
trees along our boundary friends and all
these trees will grow to a minimum of 2
feet uh 2 MERS in height
our fencing is 6 ft all around our
property he claims that there is a
feeling of loss of light and enclosure
and this may be because we've had to put
a temporary trellis on top of our fence
around our patio area where their
photographs again provided to protect
our children from abusive language aimed
at us coming from 54 even today I'm
sorry uh you need to keep it to the
issues regarding the application please
so this trellis so we've put up a
trellis and even to today there's a
camera and a microphone position from a
window on his property aimed at our
patio I'm sorry I'm sorry keep it to the
application we can categorically state
that there has been no objections from
any of our other neighbors and we've
provided two letters to support that and
that's our neighbor to our South 52 and
to our East which is five-wing close
there is a history between between our
neighbors at 54 Stone Road in us and as
we have opposed previous building
applications and I'm sorry I'm going to
have to St you um right so all I'm
saying is
that you know there is a dispute and
he's objecting to our raising our garden
and we don't think there's any thank you
very much it
yeah um with the planning applications
manager will now outline the report
thank you chair the application is
on so the application site is here
members will recall the um application
the subject of the non-determination
appeal which is to the north of the site
um so we are looking at number
52a um so as mentioned um it's a
retrospective application looking at the
ground level um at the rear where an
area of of raising the ground level has
been created so it constitutes
engineering operation which needs
planning permission um the what's
proposed uh as well as the retention of
this um this area is to um have Timber
fencing either side of the raised uh
turfed area um to avoid overlooking
either side which has been submitted uh
for approval so this is a view of the
the extent of the area um and then to
give you some idea this is looking at
the to the rear so this is Wings close
which is at the back of the property you
can see the property through there so
just look at the changeing level that
we're talking about you can see there's
a slope down on one side
uh so this is looking down with the
neighboring property uh number 54 to the
left hand side um and then this is
looking back up to the property um
there so through you can see the the
land level um as created and the view um
that you'd get if you were standing next
to the Garden into number 54 and then
turning back to the other way looking
towards 52 um as it stands at the moment
it it was considered by officers that
there is an impact on privacy on the
neighbors either side from this
particular era that's been created um
now in terms of how um we've looked to
deal with that as I mentioned I I just
will show you this just so you've got a
view of the rear so at the rear you've
got a sort of a garage area that's
associated with the property on Wings
close um but on the right hand side of
the image that you can see this is from
an upper floor window you have got a
garden area uh but there is quite a lot
of landscaping that control control
controlled by the neighboring property
at the rear that blocks out a number of
the views so what's been put forward uh
this was the original ground floor level
sorry the the land level um so what's
been proposed is you've got the actual
uh the increase in height itself but
then a a screen that would actually be
either side of um the area so if I go
back to the first image just to show you
where that goes so either side of that
so the walkway is down the side of of
where that screening would be
uh to the context on the right hand side
of the image that's the wings closed
property you can see the garage area and
again the the distance from the neighbor
there because of the Landscaping that
you've got within the site but also in
the neighboring site means that it's not
considered that causes any worse
overlooking so with the proposed fencing
it's considered the application could be
approved and therefore that's the
recommendation for approval thank
you thank you I move that the officer's
recommendation is adopted would the vice
chair please second second did and do I
have anyone who wants to councelor
bayford thank you chair um yes it's
regrettable that uh Planning Commission
wasn't sought but it seems that this was
in good faith um I do see that the level
of the garden has been raised which
could sort cause some um overlooking but
I think that the um that the residents
have gone to some length to provide
fencing which will protect the privacy
of neighbors um I think this has gone on
quite long time and I I feel that
probably at this stage it should be
approved thank
you councelor Kean thank you I think
with the screen as suggested that it
mitigates the problem so I would be
supporting
it okay I don't appear to have any other
speakers so we will now move at the
motion for the office recommendation for
approval to the vote those in
favor
yeah any against and no abstentions
thank you the motion is carried so that
concludes the public speaking for this
meeting Vice chair councelor brgh will
now take over the role of chair for the
next item on the agenda thank
you
for
okay thank you um I'll call upon the
clerk to read out the remaining planning
applications if a member wishes to
reserve an application will they please
call out as the Clark reads thank you
Vice chair A1 North Court uh sorry
Northwood Court Millennium Way uh
Millennium Way broadstairs A3 land east
of parking Bay caner Road Westminster
Ramsgate A4 JC rook and Suns limited
Cecilia Road Ramsgate and A5 8 to 25
Military Road Ram
skates I see no one calling
out can I have a proposal to move that
the app apption that have not been
reserved be determined in accordance
with the officer's recommendations okay
councelor Kean and councelor mat face
you m face second yeah
yes do members
agree thank
you um for the benefit of the public I
will call upon the clerk to read out the
applications that have been
determined thank you Vice chair the
applications have been determined are A1
Northwood Court Millennium Way
broadstairs
A3 land east of parking Bay cby Road
West Minster Ramsgate A4 JC working Suns
limited Cecilia Road Ramsgate and A5 825
Military Road Ramsgate thank
you thank you this concludes the
business for this meeting thank you for
your attendance and good
night
for